casting darcos gad elmaleh prise une
salut si pablo escobar
c'est moi qui contrôle tout ce qui
concerne la drogue les chiches la
cauquenne longs filaments des
médicaments avec ordonnance que tu peux
pas avoir pas plus qu'aux barres et
effet la livraison un lotois c'est moi
pablo escobar j'ai pas peur de la police
j'ai pas peur de la politique stable aux
cobras tabarnak pardon l'accent s'est
passé pour pour vous pour ça les fait
voyager quoi il serait le rêve
bref elles cherchent elles réelles chez
elle attend elle chauffe eau
[Applaudissements]
casting stranger things prises une par
l'ons alors moi on va des années 80 ces
années 80 je suis à fond et it is
comment ça j'ai pas l'âge et la kalach
de gamme à 11 ans
merci
[Applaudissements]
casting la sauvegarde prises une
ok donc il tape deux fois sur le bureau
afin d'asseoir son autorité
je pense que c'est moi ga simon charisme
est une autorité non
merci
[Applaudissements]
casting orange et du new black prix
d'une
ok tout le monde c'est une fouille
générale la patte de ce monde souvent ça
va assez bon façon vous êtes en prison
et c'est pas comme si vous étiez précis
où vous avez un truc à faire
faites gaffe
merci
[Applaudissements]
casting marseille gad elmaleh prise une
monsieur le maire je le sais que j'ai
grandi d'un beau pas [ __ ] est abandonnée
abandonner marseille l'om la canebière
sopra iam je laisse aux toits rouges
tu vois c'est trop ça c'est le costume
c'est le pacs en commencer un vaccin la
série s'appelle marseille ça veulent pas
à amiens waouh ça la presse va à dorer
ses 5 étoiles partout avec un bonhomme
qui rigolent et compagnie
[Applaudissements]